[Music]
i'm at the nangang exhibition center in
taipei city where foxconn is having its
2021 tech day foxton is best known for
assembling iphones for apple and it
announced three of its own eevee models
including an suv a sedan and an electric
bus
tarzan
taiwan san diego
[Music]
foxconn is the world's largest contract
electronics manufacturer and has been
moving further and further into the
automotive industry in an attempt to
diversify its business over the past
year it has announced a series of deals
and partnerships uh most recently it has
said that it will buy an ohio factory
from electric truck maker or town
motorist as part of that voice town set
that it would also use foxconn to
manufacture its vehicles including its
debut electric pickup truck
given foxconn's supply chain experience
and existing relationship with apple
that could put it in a particularly good
position
for manufacturing any potential future
apple cars as far as apple car comments
or news goes the company has not said
anything on that front
[Music]